last question right here
shaq let's just say that a uh snake bit
your mom right up here
right in the chest area would you be
willing to suck the venom out to win the
title
no but i will with your wife
[Laughter]
for you you said you know it was just
your game couldn't get into a rhythm
tonight is that what it was
based on their defense or just not not
feeling it or what
um no i was just pretty poor i mean let
me say it seemed like you only answered
you only ask questions when we lose
that's a weird thing with you kenny
i always come around we lose i swear
are you currently in a relationship are
you playing the field
oh my god okay what the [ __ ] what are
you [ __ ] no you're really having a
relationship
well that was a tough loss um how do you
feel after that how the [ __ ] you think i
feel ask no dumbass questions
get get it all out get it off i don't
feel like [ __ ] right now
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you think of my life and feel
amazing i take a loss i mean yeah
so who do you think is going to take the
victory don't give a [ __ ] stop asking
all these dumb ass questions
we lost like hey you interview now be
gone
number seven can you still dunk him when
was the last time you tried
can i still dunk are you stupid
you know i can still jump you know i can
still palm a basketball yeah i can still
do it oh man
oh damn getting
testy yeah i am testing whoa dumb
question man oh man how do i sign up to
test out your neural net program
uh well you just put this usbc port in
your head and
um
and then don't worry
i'm in it'll be fine it seems like
you're busy with something because
you're forgetting to cut your son's hair
look at his hair when are you gonna cut
that hair do you have a problem with
that no i don't have a problem some
people shave the head of their children
and people say oh isn't that terrible
well i don't even cut my son's hair and
they say oh my god when is she going to
cut her son's hair right you know there
was that rumor where that you had a male
appendage that you were a hermaphrodite
and you joked about it on the stage last
night maybe i do
but but it's interesting would it be so
terrible but essentially a lot of
artists would immediately put out some
sort of statement saying this is
absolutely not true
you have fun with it why the hell am i
going to waste my time and give a press
release about whether or not i have a
penis my fans don't care neither do i
i'm going to ask you this and it's
embarrassing for me to ask you this but
i'm going to ask you anyway are you a
virgin
how could you ask me that question i'm
just i just want to know i want to i'm a
gentleman you're a gentleman i'm a
gentleman
so i'm a gentleman and therefore
something that's private i mean
you know shouldn't be spoken about
openly you can call me old-fashioned if
you want but
you know to me that's very personal
so you're not going to answer it i'm
embarrassed
um you're five hours late here man shut
the [ __ ] up come on man no we just saw
you on twitter
five hours late [ __ ] i'm here [ __ ] be
happy i'm here and ask some real
questions yeah i was just wondering what
you what you know why you were so late
and i saw you were twittering about
stopped me being stuffed at the porter i
was late because i went to go get some
chicken wings
that's why i was late counter question
for you you have won exactly one fight
since barack obama was president
[Applause]
[Applause]
but they also know that you you know you
have some shock value to you i mean
you're on the cover of your book you're
wearing a fur and you knew that there
would probably be animal rights action
you know this whole interview is
becoming a defensive interview
are you wearing leather shoes yes
things are clearly going brilliantly in
your career i just wondered if you are
as happy in your private life and will
we be seeing our certain mr ashton
kutcher perhaps making a trip over here
wow how disappointing was that question
should we move on to another one
absolutely i think that was the quest
we're going to move on i think it's
quickly and i'm single if that's what
you're really asking given interviews
you've done in the past um your own
sexuality seems a bit more ambiguous do
you find it hard for celebrities to talk
to their sex to talk to media about
their sexuality
what on earth do you want about
but what is your question
i was wondering if you find it difficult
for celebrities to talk about their
sexuality i don't find it difficult for
celebrities to talk about their
sexuality
um are you asking me about my sexuality
sure
why why
um thank you okay
you know the dark periods you entered
and and taking drugs and drinking and
all of that you know you you think
you're free of all of that
or whether that's still something sorry
i i really don't
what are we doing
well i'm just asking questions that's
all right
bye thank you guys you've admitted that
you're lazy i think you've read six
books in your life i've read six six
what kind of a woman would be attracted
to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
[Applause]
joaquin directly in front of you uh
chris with gma philippines the movie
obviously is about the joker but it goes
beyond that it's really about um the the
mental state he was in can you tell me a
little bit about what research or what
kind of uh
what you did to prepare for this because
this was really an intense performance
um what was kind of the process of
getting into that mindset
is this old news
isn't this old news didn't i do that i
feel like i've talked about this for six
months
what
i mean right i mean i feel like i i
answer these questions questions you you
want it again it's like a different you
want to hear a different version of it
i try and change it slightly or what
should i do
do you numb yourself to
i don't know if there's ever i don't
know if there's a man alive who's not in
love with you in some way you're so
silly you know what i'm i'm am i really
you're silly no i'm not serious silly
man in a checkered shirt i am not wow
wow
you have to go into every situation when
you have a conversation with a man
you've never met that is going to end at
some point with him flirting with you no
absolutely not johnny's never flirted
with me once you've stated that you
believe there could be an infinite
number of parallel universes does that
mean that there is a universe out there
where i am smarter than you
yes and also a universe where you're
funny
but are you still considered the fat guy
when you go to a party or anything
because i run into that a whole lot i'm
the fat one
okay so does that just are you the fat
guy in hollywood still or or does
everybody like look at you and they're
like oh wow you know this is great now
you're healthy uh do you have any other
questions that are smart you shoot
greedo first or did greedo shoot you
first
um i don't care
[Music]
so your christian background is is part
of the the show yes and i wanted to talk
to you about jesus after that well
the only reason why i bring it up but
some people thought maybe you went a
little too far you know as far as what
well they thought that maybe you were
being disrespectful to the christian
religion
i'm telling you you need to
google oh good lord so did you feel you
would be disrespectful or just you you
were just having fun with some of the
crucifixes and
stuff like that
i don't even know what you i mean we did
maybe two jokes about that yeah exactly
don't you think the catholic church went
a little too far
more so than my cartoon all right listen
a couple of jokes i know this is a
morning show you can't bring up all
those crimes you know what they just
they just sort of kept moving them
around you know like those killer whales
at sea world after it kills a trainer
they'll then move it up to seattle they
don't give them their background
all right i'm not totally following
but i don't think you know what i'm
talking about it's a morning show i
understand that anytime
that kid would miss the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know and
one i was joking earlier if that kid's
story about the graduation was late
night that would have been a whole
different story what do you think he's
still missing we can't find him all we
found was his hat but you watch in the
morning it's great it all worked out he
got his own personal graduation like i
was in such a great mood look how yellow
this couch is it's like the sun do you
get philippa being so branded in that
way in a sense though you know of saying
that you know she's a source yeah i
think there must be some truth in it
people keep saying it
there's uh
i think they're right
[Laughter]
i hope they're not but you are what you
are and you are what other people think
you are and uh you can't avoid that
do you think i mean you are um in quotes
a serious actress um you know seriously
you know it's because the kind of cliche
was a serious actress as opposed to an
unserious actress um but do you find in
fact that this what could be best
described as your equipment in fact
hinders you perhaps in that pursuit
i'd like you to explain what you mean by
my equipment
well people watch great detail
well i think that they might sort of
detract from a performance if you know
what i mean really
oh i i can't think that can necessarily
be true i mean what a crummy performance
if people are obsessed with the size of
your bosom or anything else
i would hope that uh
the performance and the play and the
living relationship
between all the people on stage and all
the people in the audience overcome such
boring
questions
beautiful ladies like you two beautiful
women
uh it's very hard to do this acting
especially on those days what do you
mean because because there's a beautiful
art yeah because sometimes on those days
you're starting to be angry to be
furious uh you keep fighting on each
other on those days you know it's not so
hard sometimes yeah i think especially
on those days i think there is some uh
some like stereotypes maybe that women
um are you know very catty on set with
each other um but that doesn't really
happen on our set it's just you're
wondering in this question oh i get
because i think i i i can't tell there's
like um i feel like it's accidentally
maybe a little bit misogynistic because
it's like you're so beautiful what's it
like having to do all that acting
i can't tell if that's the question but
if it is it's insane